i will say probably the the thing that i
very quickly got adjusted to that i
think that will
hit me like whiplash when i return is uh
deliveries here
oh because are you speaking of optimized
you get so used to it here because what
happens is
uh we spoke about this on the podcast
before do we have i don't think so so
when you get a delivery
in like i guess any other country it's
like we'll arrive between 8am and 6pm
and you just got to be home on a tuesday
hope you listen out
you know and then you [ __ ] miss it
and knockout yeah and they didn't knock
on the door
they say that they were there and it's
like [ __ ]
and then it's this whole [ __ ] pain
that you've got to try and reschedule
like oh well you come back in
four days and it's like are you kidding
me i pre-ordered this game
i wanted it today but in japan
when you miss a package not only can you
reschedule on that day
within a two-hour time slot so if you
miss it between like 8 and 12 a.m which
is the only four-hour time slot yeah you
can get it re-deliver between
12 and two four and six six and eight
nine two
same day literally the whole day and you
can pick the two hours
it's nuts and on amazon when you do it
you can also pick the two hour time slot
it's
nuts yeah it's so insane and it works i
mean i mean there are also like what is
it where
the uk and stuff some places have like
in london have like amazon now or
something like that yeah
that's insane that's that that's insane
i think i spoke with that in the podcast
for because i ordered like mario party
and [ __ ] oh yeah
it's when it arrives literally a few
hours after you order it
man honestly i wouldn't be surprised if
japan gets it yeah yeah yeah i mean i
would love that because
i didn't know i would never leave my
house i just [ __ ] get it well it was
made for groceries mainly
oh yeah yeah which which is weird like
because i was thinking back to our
podcast last week
with uh uh with alexion and i remember
thinking to myself man
how would i have survived in japan and
got set up
if amazon didn't exist like like he did
like like when he first moved here and
i'm just thinking man so much of my life
has revolved around
amazon in japan that if i didn't have it
i would be like life would be 10 times
harder
it does become when something isn't on
amazon i've noticed it becomes about 10
times more difficult yeah
to get the thing that i want and
delivered because you have to look it up
and being like all right where's the
closest store and then you have to find
out when the stores open
and then you have to go in and [ __ ]
look for it it's just yeah
it's a mess gross but i also think i
also feel kind of sad because i feel
that
because everything is so easy
you know and i i i got comments that
were like a couple of kind of complains
about not knowing japanese
and living in japan right not
complaining i'm just [ __ ] british and
i'm just complaining about the things
that i complain about i i know it's my
fault for not knowing jack
he's not a [ __ ] idiot i know that
it's probably not a good idea
to not speak japanese in japan
but a lot of people do come here to
learn yeah right and i do think that if
i was forced
to you know say 10 years ago or 15 years
ago
i think that i would have been forced to
learn a lot more oh yeah because
i would have no choice all right all
right right now i don't need to do
anything
google maps tells you where to go google
maps tells me the restaurants i can
google translate every web page yeah
like
it's pretty much all sort of it's it's
catering more towards foreigners
definitely
it also doesn't help that this is
basically a society that has optimized
like getting getting the least amount of
human interaction posture
you go to a restaurant you have a tablet
and you order your stuff you know you do
so most of the time you don't even need
to talk to anyone you know what i mean
which is why i like i get you must get
this a lot right do you get comments
asking you like how's your japanese
coming along how's your japanese
kangaroo
yeah gone how is it coming it is
is it josu it is i've already gotten
josie a few times
it's difficult right because it's hard
to explain because essentially
i don't i think people have a
misconception of how much we interact
with japanese people
yeah i talk to a japanese person and i'm
forced to speak japanese
at like most often at the kombini or
at the like danny's or whatever like at
a restaurant or a store
those are the three most common times
and there's a script like i know exactly
what they're going to say yeah yeah
they always say i know exactly what you
mean because we were we were getting
coffee like i think it was last week or
something at the bookwalk offices and we
kind of ordered the coffee and he almost
sounded like [ __ ] fluent with
like all the responses he was making and
he was just and it was just like
i know how it is where you've ordered
something enough times that you just
know the questions you get
yeah i perfectly optimized ordering
coffee it's like when you watch a movie
and you say the line before the actress
i know what you're gonna say and i know
where the if that script is like varied
like in the slightest you just go
you just go like i have no idea what the
[ __ ] i'm doing anymore because what
happens is i'll be ordering coffee right
and here's the order every single time
you go in there you say what you want
they'll ask you do you want it to stay
or to go
yeah you say to go and then i'll ask you
you know do you want a bag
you say no you don't want a bag and then
you just say how you want to pay so you
can just say that
right and that's always how it is and
every time it goes wrong and if joey's
with me i'll just slowly turn to joe and
be like
there's only two times i've seen a slow
head turn that's in a horror movie and
when i'm with you guys and you it's out
of the script
it's just a very slow like i don't want
to go yeah i don't want to go
joey help i just want to be like dozo
joe
i'll leave it it's it's actually funny
when you're not there because when it's
something there have been times when
it's just me and connor and we're at
like a restaurant ordering something and
then we get we get something off script
and it's both of us trying to keep uh
like cumulatively
figure out which one of us knows like as
much japanese as each other like
like we're trying to like combine our
japanese knowledge to be like okay you
know this word i know that word
so we can let's try and figure out what
was that combining these two words
together
that's the thing though like that's like
one like i'm such a [ __ ] sadist but
like that's the one thing i [ __ ] love
when friends who can't speak japanese
i'm hanging out with [ __ ]
and we go to like a restaurant or
something or we go out somewhere or go
traveling somewhere is that
because i don't look japanese people
don't expect me to know japanese yeah so
i love every now and then going to a
restaurant with like a bunch of
non-japanese friends and pretending i
can't speak
to japanese
so yeah outside of you know those
situations i we pretty much don't really
speak to japanese people
although to be fair you've been recently
[ __ ] interacted with like japanese
people on apex all right well so i i
thought to myself right
i'm taking these japanese classes two
times the problem is is i'm not really
doing much outside of that and you
people will
be like oh why don't you study more i
mean the work schedule that we have is
already
pretty [ __ ] and there's only so much
studying before you have to actually use
it in practice
right i think like no matter how much
studying i do if i'm not using it yeah
yeah like practically it's not gonna
happen yeah there's no point so yeah i
just decided [ __ ] it okay you know what
i'm gonna
i'm gonna stream talking to japanese
people on apex trying to make friends
yeah
managed to make some friends pretty
[ __ ] fast yeah okay even though most
people do not want to talk
i mean i was tuning into one of your
streams and you were like interacting
quite
well i i can speak super super basic and
yeah but they were getting it
yeah yeah yeah they can normally
understand what i'm trying to say the
best thing is is that if i don't know
something
i'm like chat chat what is this word how
do i say this thing and then they tell
me and then
i don't forget it yeah because i'm using
it like a meter over and over
and so that's been really helpful and if
you want to go and watch those you can
watch them on the highlights whatever
they're doing um but yeah that that's
been super helpful but outside of that
like we don't [ __ ] use it like
i mean you can you i i can talk to you
guys but it's okay joey it's different
because
it's it's different joey it's because
you know how bad we are and it's
embarrassing right no no okay okay you
got you have to throw that aside because
like i am fine doing it in front of two
thousand people live
yeah but not in front of me no not why
because
i'm not gonna judge you [ __ ]
we judge ourselves when we win it's it's
like a subconscious thing where i'm just
like
i want you to be disappointed in me
jerry i'm not going to be disappointed i
want to just impress you man i want to
impress you okay
i just want to get any hunger joseph
okay but i i know how jose your japanese
is man i
i can't i can't reach that level right
now man you're like trying to impress
your dad
it's like come on man this is the only
time i'm gonna get my dad's love
because i don't know what it is about
talking to a japanese person i i even
though it's even more awkward because if
they don't understand me we're [ __ ]
yeah but it's less awkward because they
inherently expect me to be
[ __ ] awful yeah so it's it's like
when i do do good it's like oh awesome
like it's good so then why don't you
just put that on me because
you you can probably figure out what i'm
trying to say and you could be like you
trying to say this
but i can also just pretend to be like
i guess you know but it's
the point is in general we don't really
get to talk to as many japanese people
as
i think people expect us to yeah right